mais oui ça se passait en mars dernier
1300 employés de l'usiné electrolux de
l'assomption dans lanaudière apprenait
que leur entreprise fermait
définitivement ses portes le 18 juillet
c'est à dire dans un mois d'ici depuis
les cas de détresse psychologique
augmente si bien que des travailleurs
éprouvent des pensées suicidaires et ont
besoin d'être en ce moment je dis verso
des jours gris parfois même noirci tout
ce qu'on a l'impression de voir c'est un
si bon nombre de travailleurs
d'electrolux je me serais mort sa grosse
dépression majeure
je sais qu hormis à 52 ans il a passé sa
vie dans cette usine
les employés ont appris cet hiver que
l'établissement fermera définitivement
ses portes le 18 juillet la production
sera transférée dans une nouvelle usine
à memphis aux états unis on a un certain
deuil avril après 31 ans de service
n'oublie pas toujours aux larmes et la
peau sont ainsi qu'avec ta famille la
détresse psychologique a augmenté
certains travailleurs ont même des
pensées suicidaires
présentement le centre de prévention du
suicide newzik qu'il reçoit une hausse
d'apple qui n'était pas là il y a même
pas un mois c'est des hommes parce qu'on
fait face book ou une clientèle d'hommes
donc c'est des sommes qui vont
qu'apprennent qui vont perdre leur
emploi donc nécessairement une réaction
le quai qui est tout à fait normal y'a
pas au juge osé penser il ya incorporé à
la sicile vont pas demander de l'aide ou
guy séris la ville et la mrc de
l'assomption ont élaboré plusieurs
stratégies pour tirer de nouveaux
emplois dans la région
mais disent maintenant avoir besoin de
façon urgente de l'aide du nouveau
gouvernement du québec gouvernement
provincial ici la voie d'accotement qui
devrait avec 12
le maire souhaiterait que le
gouvernement actuel appuyé
officiellement les plans d'affaires de
la ville comme l'avait fait le
gouvernement précédent
une bouée de sauvetage selon lui dont
ont grandement besoin les employés ici
julie marceau radio-canada à
l'assomption